[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday July 10th
oh the doth picture
I knew the goth fixture is going to come
back oh it's back Johnson's we made a
simultaneous infraction more of us I've
been thinking that it would be great to
do a simultaneous punishment like a
punishment that played off itself each
of us does a similar punishment which is
why I was excited about me getting a
mohawk and you getting an inverse mohawk
so together we would have one normal
haircut but I understand that the Yeti
doesn't want a husband with an inverse
mohawk I understand that for now watch
out because it might happen
and I am in favor of it happening but
since you've settled on my punishment
already I would have to make your
punishment play off my punishment the
only way I could do that is if I had a
really embarrassing picture of you oh I
do
apparently I have several really
embarrassing pictures of you how did
that happen
let's spend some time with each of these
pictures they seem to all be from high
school which makes a good parallel with
my embarrassing picture because it is
also from high school now it's pretty
embarrassing that two of these seem to
be from academic decathlon meets
academic decathlon meets in which you
had a maroon buzzcut additionally their
academic decathlon meets in would you
seem to have done very well another of
them is just you shirtless in pants that
are obviously falling off doing what
looks to be a version of your happy
dance now I certainly wouldn't mind
seeing you recreate that picture
nerdfighters just make the video black
and white put on some really big pants
take off your shirt and do your happy
dance I really do want these punishments
to match up so I'm just going to take
one of these academic decathlon pictures
and I'm gonna match it with my
embarrassing picture so let's look at
them as a whole here's my picture it is
very embarrassing here's your picture it
is very embarrassing
now I think we should figure out what
the most embarrassing part of each of
these pictures is and my picture I think
we can agree that the most embarrassing
part of the picture is my face because
of all of my goth makeup but in your
picture I think that we can agree that
the most embarrassing part is your face
because of your cute little face and
your cute gigantic glasses and your
amazing maroon buzzcut now I think that
we should discuss the most embarrassing
non facial part of each of these
pictures for me I think it's my limp
wrist and for you I think I'm gonna go
with your adorable shiny golden bowtie
and finally I think that we should
discuss our left eyes here's mine and
here's your's Wow
so John my punishment to you unless you
add something else on to mind is to
recreate one of those two pictures
either the one with the golden bowtie or
the one where you're doing that dance
and I'm only giving you the option
because I'm not entirely sure you're
going to be able to find a golden bowtie
and it's just not going to work without
the golden bowtie
so hopefully by Friday I'm going to see
this guy or possibly this guy but I will
see you tomorrow